سموم الأفيال يغادر WN 14 alayka ،
لكنني Dalek وأدخلنا
حياة جامدة رأينا الآخرين
يركضون وكنا مثل يا إلهي
إنهم يهربون مثل ما يحدث ، لقد
سميت زوجي إنه مثل
لعبة خدمة القطن الفيل  الرقم الصحيح
الذي يشبهه في السيارة ، كان كارين
قائدًا هالاتا أليسيو أوتاوا بواسطة دي
إيتوربيد ، ألقى ويلما سقيفة باسيفلورا إلى
ألفيل في باراثا التاريخية ماديرا
بهلوانية وأنا متأكد من أننا نشتري
مقطورتين ديبيكا أحتاج إلى أي شيء
فقط المعجنات أي نوع من الطعام يمكنك
أخبرهم أنهم كانوا مستائين جدًا مثل يا إلهي ،
تأكد من أن الحيوانات التي تعرفها
تتدهور كانت مستاءة للغاية وخائفة جيدًا لم أكن غير ذلك مثل الهوا ناتال هاكاتا دوران بيج دي مير كابوت
شودا أسد إيكولو في آدم هوروفيتس الله
و  من
المحتمل جدًا أن يكون مادوف في مرفق mfa سياتل ، لكنهم كانوا خائفين للغاية
وكان الناس يحاولون
حساب المرأة التي تعرفها كانوا يحاولون
استعادة الجميع bad estoy fuera de
alla fiera Thomas Emm  الذي سمح لها بإطلاق النار
عليها في المحور